bonjour à tous hier soir les sénateurs
ont débattu de la corse et de la réforme
territoriale
à l'initiative du groupe rdse
ce groupe à majorité de radicaux de
gauche hier les aura atteint des
différents groupes se sont aussi bien
exprimé sur les questions
institutionnelles que constitutionnel
sur le développement économique sur le
logement ou encore sur la spéculation
foncière sur l'île de beauté et il ya
une question qui a traversé
l'intégralité du débat c'est la
république une et indivisible est elle
compatible avec la diversité de ses
territoires
je rappelle que ce débat devait se
dérouler juste avant l'examen au sénat
de la première partie de la réforme
territoriale ce devait être aujourd'hui
l'examen de la carte des nouvelles
régions une réforme pour l'instant
ajournée au sénat est suspendu à la
décision du conseil constitutionnel tout
de suite donc retour à ce débat c'est
hier soir au sénat on commence par
l'allocution de nicolas alfonsi
sénateurs rdse et élus de corse
la séance est reprise
l'ordre du jour appelle le débat sur la
corse et la réforme territoriale
la parole est tout d'abord à l'orateur
du groupe qui a demandé ce débat je
rappelle donc nico nicolas alfonsi pour
le groupe rds se
coucha collègues vous avez la parole
re bonjour
madame la présidente
seul ministre
chers collègues
mes premiers mots seront pour me réjouir
comme l'ensemble de la communauté
nationale
pour ce beau succès encore une des
nouveaux de la france
et qui est
l'expression d'une solidarité que nous
souhaitons solidarité et tendre à
beaucoup d'autres domaines
je voudrais également remercier monsieur
le ministre
d'avoir bien voulu accepter
ce débat dont je dois dire que
est il encore sans objet ou bien mérite
il encore d'être étudiés parce que nous
étions convenus d'un débat à la fin mais
je pense qu'il faut le savoir
votre voyage en corse
ne pouvait pas permettre de déflorer ce
que vous alliez dire et que par
conséquent de l'avoir poussé
vous avez apporté un certain nombre de
clarifications nécessaires
sur la situation d'il
vous avez en même temps laisser planer
quelques clair obscur quelques zones
d'ombré je pense qu'il sera peut être
nécessaire que vous précisiez sauce
tomate votre pensée
il s'agit en effet de leva sur
l'organisation territoriale de la corse
dans l'esprit dans notre esprit il
s'agissait au départ d'évoquer tous les
problèmes de la corse je ne pourrai donc
les évoqué d'une manière extrêmement
haut quercy
et je crois que l'essentiel pour bien
comprendre le débat qui s'imposent
aujourd'hui à nous
c'est d'avoir un esprit de données
fondamentales telles que j'estime
personnellement pendant longtemps la
première c'est qu'existe une
revendication permanente d'une
légitimité corse de d'une légitimité de
l'assemblée de corse des élus de la
corse
qui est une pseudo légitimité bien
entendu puisque en invoquant permanence
ce droit à
a déposé des motions a évoqué des droits
qui ne relèvent pas de la compétence en
mal d'une institution il tombe sous le
sens que le débat c'est toujours
extrêmement difficile à ce stade là de
le deuxième la deuxième donnée c'est ce
sentiment permanent
qu'on en corse de la différence je les
caricatures et ma pensée
mais
d'une certaine façon
il suffirait que la république devienne
un état fédéral
pourquoi obligé de demander
l'indépendance on a toujours de cette
différence
ce qui signifie que il faut le répéter
tant que nous n'en prenons ne vous
imprégner pas des tas de cet état
d'esprit permanent de revendications
tout à la fois d'une légitimité d'une
différence il tombe sous le sens que le
dialogue devient un dialogue extrêmement
difficile alors je vais très vite quatre
engagements quatre ans
sinon fait le retour en arrière il ya
une sorte de fatalité décennale
82 réforme 92 les années 90 2000 de 2012
il se trouve que l'assemblée de corse a
été élu à gauche en 2010 et que depuis
2010 il ne s'écoule pas un mois sans
qu'un permanents font se remette sur le
chantier de la réforme institutionnelle
ou constitution ce n'est pas tout à fait
la même chose et que ce débat récurrent
bien entendu vient de s'achever par les
trois délibérations que vous connaissez
monsieur le ministre
la co officialité je l'évacué l'évacuer
d'un trait vous avez dire ajaccio ce que
nous attendions n'ont pas non plus sauf
que font ceux qui me concerne je serai
toujours partisan et éventuellement
j'accepterai toujours la possibilité
d'une heure
révision constitutionnelle la fameuse
proposition 56 du président hollande qui
concernerait toutes les régions mais
j'ai toujours manifester mon opposition
totale comme vous d'ailleurs
opposition à des dispositions qui serait
exclusivement spécifique à la société
corse suffit de lire le mot les propos
qui ont été tenus et la délibération qui
concerne la sociaux lingerie le consul
français en tant que langue officielle
et eric thal d'accord peuvent être
employées directement dans les services
dans les parties dans l'espace public
arrêtons les frais n'en parlons plus
vous avez dit là des choses qu'il
fallait dire je ne pense pas qu'il soit
nécessaire d'y revenir deuxième
délibération
nous actons ce que vous avez dit la
délibération sur le statut de résident
je rappelle je rappe que je rappelle
encore une fois que dans ce domaine
ne peuvent ne pourront acheter encore ce
que les personnes qui en cinq ans de
résidence les personnes morales y aura
donc des personnes physiques puis des
personnes morales vous avez insisté là
dessus on sait ce qui pourrait se passer
avec les personnes morales et puis
j'ajoute que dans ces contorsions dans
ces banques françaises dans cette
contorsion permanente pour tenter de
trouver une place à ce que l'on appelle
la diaspora on a inventé un dispositif
qui devait venir ministre vous réjouir
parce que vous
finalement vous pourrez acheter
votre passage à ce village corse qui
vous a ramené à l'enfance vous donne un
droit vous donne un droit parce que il
ya quelque part dans le texte si une
sensible on trouve dans votre caractère
le centre des intérêts moraux et
matériels qui se situerait dans une
commune de corse vous pourrez acheter ne
vous imaginez la broglio juridique dans
lequel on rentrerait dans ces situations
surréalistes quand on tente de nous
imposer donc encore une fois de ce côté
là je dirais que j'ai trop de respect
pour mes amis pour parler de ce qu'ils
quand on lit des histoires pareilles
voilà je crois que les élus ont déposé
un texte a été voté mais j'observe en
même temps que ce texte a été voté avec
une majorité descendante parce qu'il n'a
plus que de 29 personnes
survenant amateurs personnes qui ont
voté pour et 19 qui ont voté contre j'en
viens je crois au troisième problème qui
me paraît le plus fondamental et là je
dois dire que je n'ai pas réussi à
décrypter
à décrypter votre texte lui c'est un
texte lu de votre part bien entendu
c'est très important parce que chaque
mot pèse
quand vous évoquez le problème de la
réforme constitutionnelle
j'y viens une d'une délibération
droite et gauche confondues a été
inventé pour solliciter l'introduction
dans l'article 72 5 un article
supplémentaire du mot corse je ne dis
pas que cela relève du fétichisme mais
une droite et gauche confondues ont voté
cette délibération
c'est bien entendu l'auberge espagnole
car pour les nationalistes pour une
partie de la gauche bien entendu vous
introduire le statut de résident qui
n'est pas constitutionnelle
et pour la droite il s'agit d'y
introduire le droit de chasser le droit
de pêche ce qui veut dire que
cela ne peut pas prospérer mais il ya
une cause à cela la cause c'est le flnc
pourquoi parce que non quand vous lisez
le texte de la délibération
pour disait que l'assemblée une demande
vouloir engager à cette fin sur la base
du rapport et c'est une discussion
approfondie avec les élus de la corse la
proposition de la création d'un article
112 5 voilà ça c'est le contenu de la
délibération une discussion avec les
élus de la corse mais c'est ce que dit
le flnc on supprime le mot négociation
avec les evil d'accord c'est une
question sémantique et on joue on dit
simplement une discussion en 30 ans dit
pourquoi parce que dans sa dernière
déclaration
je vous rassure tout de suite je ne vais
pas m'excuser parce que je ne me suis
jamais épuisé pour compter pour discuter
avec l'organisation commenter les propos
de l'organisation clandestine mais je ne
peux pas m'empêcher de dire que le flnc
demande aux élus insulaires je le cite
l'instauration d'un nouveau statut
négocié avec l'état français alors tout
est dit vous avez une délibération
l'assemblée de corse qui demande une
discussion avec l'état pour la réponse
constitutionnel et vous avez en même
temps le flnc qui dit exactement la même
chose
pourquoi parce que depuis dix ans
j'étais bien depuis dix ans
tout le débat a porté sur quel surcroît
il a simplement porté sur le souci que
les nationalistes
modérés pas modérés ne rentrons pas dans
ce genre de distinction elle ne dépasse
que les nationalistes ont toujours eu le
souci de discuter sur un pied d'égalité
avec l'état
c'est la nouvelle calédonie c'est à dire
que autant en nouvelle calédonie vous
avez de l'article 88 qui qui égrène qui
liste tous les objets toutes les
compétences ce qui pose plus de problème
constitutionnel puisque l'article 88
aprue les accords de nouméa et de
matignon avec l'énumération de toutes
les compétences transférées ici vous
êtes dans la situation où on ne peut pas
faire le saut puisque les rapports de
force étant ce qu'ils sont on ne peut
pas aller très loin on ne peut pas faire
le saut mais on est obligé et vous êtes
obligé de donner à fait que la volonté
souterraine constante dans la durée
c'est bien celle à établir des rapports
d'égalité entre les rapports la fameuse
légitimité dont je parlais entre les
élus de la corse et les trains alors
vous nous dites
l'histoire de la corse on a su l'arrêter
vous faites allusion à l'inscription de
la corse à la constitution vous avez
demandé d'instruction de l'accord dans
la constitution
l'histoire de l'accord son insularité
son identité peuvent naturellement
justifier cette aspiration à la
singularité
institutionnels
institutionnels constitutionnel monsieur
le ministre c'est tout le débat
voilà car nous sommes là au coeur du
dispositif
parce que j'attends encore qu'on nous
donne une réponse j'avais demandé au
président hollande puisque pendant
quatre ans on a en permanence évoqué ce
problème qui ne serait peut-être temps
que l'état au lieu de a invoqué toujours
l'absence d'une majorité
au congrès pour provoquer le vote d'un
amendement constitutionnel
il était peut-être temps qu'à un moment
donné le président la république est lui
même une opinion sur le fond et nous
disent s'ils étaient pour ou s'ils
étaient contre et quand je vous lis je
lis que cette inspiration à la
singularité constitue institutionnels le
gouvernement sera attentif aux
propositions dont vous le saisir et et
j'observe que le dialogue est engagé
dans cette perspective cette discussion
sans tabou notre constitution
admet le droit à l'expérimentation des
territoires de la république sans blague
est lesquels les carry trades la
république
quand vous avez l'article 72 il dit
qu'il peut y avoir des expérimentations
attitude qu'on peut prendre des
initiatives pour sortir du cadre mais
c'est dans un cadre extrêmement
restreint là nous sommes sortis du
dispositif qui permet l'expérimentation
pour entrer dans le cadre encore une
fois constitutionnelle pendant
clairement le vrai débat qui existe
entre nous c'est le dernier d'ailleurs
c'est celui que je viens d'évoquer et je
crois qu'il serait peut-être nécessaire
que sur ce point toute la lumière soit
faite en un mot oui ou non pouvez vous
un seul instant envisagé qu'il puisse y
avoir à la demande des élus de la corse
qui se situerait sur un pied d'égalité
avec l'état et puisse envisager une
réforme de la constitution un article 72
l'article 72 500 à dire nouveau entre
guillemets
ne changera strictement rien au problème
du principe d'égalité devant la loi du
préambule jean page des principes
fondamentaux qui sont invoquées henry
régulièrement par le conseil
constitutionnel mais la difficulté qui
pourrait se présenter si on s'inscrit
dans la longue durée c'est que si cet
article était adopté eh bien on se
retrouverait ensuite dans une situation
inextricable et on vous demandera
d'aller vers d'autres dispositions
constitutionnelles qui nous
éloigneraient encore un peu plus de la
république voilà donc il y en a un vrai
débat je ne vais pas plus loin je
m'arrête mais je crois que c'est un vrai
problème qui nous interpellent et auquel
il faudrait peut-être à un moment donné
au bout de quatre ans de palabres le
débat mensuel
sur ce thème comme s'il n'y avait pas
autre chose à faire en corse que dave
après avoir évoqué qu'un juriste décote
quatre juristes dit carcassonne des
comités de tous les côtés payer des
études et cetera nous arrivons
maintenant au bout au modus yona il faut
simplement que l'on clarifie la
situation et et si je vous ai dit que si
j'ai commencé par dire ce que je ne veux
pas ce victor hugo qui évoquait dans un
discours l'enseignement je commencerai
par dire ce que je veux moi je dis je
commencerai par dire ce que je ne veux
pas non plus maintenant je peux dire ce
que je veux tout cas ce que je souhaite
c'est que dans le cadre de la réforme
territoriale
n'ayant jamais été opposé un seul
instant à toute adaptation
institutionnelle cette fois du statut du
statut de la corse je pense qu'il ya là
un vrai débat que nous devons engager
ensemble je sais bien que la
collectivité territoriale à apporter des
amendements à la marge au texte à
l'article 13 je crois au texte en
commission se prononcer sur ce point au
texte qui a été prise qui brise qui est
présenté par madame le brancher sur la
réforme territoriale des modifications à
la marge on peut donner à l'accord on
peut en parler mais tout ça est marginal
le vrai problème qui se pose
c'est de s'interroger sur un certain
nombre de problèmes de fond qui nous
interpelle je vois que le temps passe
madame la présidente et la gentillesse
d'accorder cinq minutes
dont je vois que le temps passe et je
crois qu'il faut s'interroger je m'en
étais à deux trois observations dans un
débat sur lequel je suis prêt
personnellement par apporter mon
concours bien entendu parce que je crois
qu'il faut probablement modifier sur
certains aspects le texte qui nous régit
actuellement les deux observations les
plus importantes que je voudrais faire
concerne le régime électoral
je me suis épuisé à obtenir du congrès
dans un amendement constitutionnel
le concept des statuts particuliers
le gouvernement raffarin avait bien
voulu accepter chose rare à versailles a
bien voulu accepter le souci que j'avais
d'accrocher la corde la vision d'un
statut particulier un article
constitutionnel qui aux demandes
actuelles ont fait des petits
pardonnez-moi ailleurs puisque le grand
lyon maintenant s'accroche à ce statut
ça c'était du particulier mais le deuil
la deuxième réponse que j'ai obtenu a
été trop juste trop étriqué j'avais
obtenu du sénat et je lui en sais gré
que l'on passe dans la prime accordée à
l'analyse qui arrive en tête je pense au
régime électoral une des couches
d'ailleurs de désordre actuel les
esprits paraître venir du fait qu'il n'y
a pas de majorité j'avais donc indiqué
qu' il fallait pour augmenter la prime
mais j'ai joué trop petit bras si joseph
faisait c'était un peu juste
-la prime en corse actuellement été
porté à 9 x 10 c'est à dire à 10 7% au
lieu de 25 selon le régime général ce
qui veut dire quoi ce qui veut dire que
nous sommes dans un régime
d'inégalités
d'inégalités parce que les corses
devraient avoir droit eux aussi
avec la prime à un dispositif électoral
qui les met sur un pied d'égalité avec
une prime au moins 25% de manière à
pouvoir gouverner
et cela
cela n'est pas possible aujourd'hui ce
qui crée des situations extrêmement
difficiles quand il s'agit de voir des
majorités vous connaissez la suite donc
mon france avant tout ce qui peut se
passer en termes d'accords qui ne sont
pas généralement respectée ceci est le
premier point donc respect du principe
d'égalité droit des corses à avoir un
régime électoral identique au régime
national c'est-à-dire nécessité
d'augmenter la prime deuxième
observation
la disparition d'un département
j'ai toujours été fermement attachés aux
départements
je parle au passé composé j'ai toujours
été attaché au département je veux ni
par m'interroger j'ai toujours pensé que
dans une collectivité comme la corse
qui dispose actuellement entre les trois
budgets des trois plus grosses
collectivités environs d'un budget ou de
budget de un milliard deux cents
millions d'euros ou 1 milliards d'euros
ce qui est considérable j'ai toujours
pensé qu'il fallait éviter la
recentralisation
et que si mon dieu on fait des bêtises
dans un département pour une gestion
médiocre elle pouvait peut-être être
compensée par des esprits vertueux dans
d'autres collectivités et par conséquent
où
il faut que le pauvre ans divise pouvoir
selon la formule célèbre donc je pensais
qu'il fallait diviser le pouvoir mais à
l'expérience je me rends compte que plus
rien n'est évident et aujourd'hui je
pense qu'une réflexion devrait être
faite sur ce point la seule question qui
vaille et je termine sur ce point cette
affaire sur cette réforme la vraie
question qui vaille c'est simplement de
savoir si cette réforme territoriale
corse appelons ça un nouveau statut on
doit être faite à chaud parce que
pendant quatre ans on a perdu du temps
s'ils ont des problèmes qui n'existait
pas en tout cas qu'il n'était pas
l'objet d'une demande très forte de
l'opinion si cette demande doit être
faite à chaud ou bien donc s'insérer
précipitamment dans la réforme
territoriale telle qu'il est engagé
aujourd'hui on vient si on doit se
donner le temps puisque nous ne sont pas
concernés par la réforme
la carte des territoires ne sont pas
concernés par la carte ou bien si on
doit envisager d'y réfléchir plus
longuement de la faire à froid je sais
que madame le ministre vien vendredi en
corse c'est une vraie question alors
globalement ce que je voulais dire
j'aurais pu parler longtemps nous avons
parlé des impôts n'ont pas non plus vous
connaissez la france célèbre il ya des
gens qui meurent de faim à la moindre
fumée du vésuve ils sont saisis
d'angoise ils ont peur de mourir loin
d'être malheureux
la situation fiscale encore un peu la
même chose bon je pourrais parler de la
loi littoral je pourrais dire
où tout le monde encore ce pan stratégie
d'un patrimoine qui n'a pas si de connu
c'est là où je pourrais parler de la loi
littoral on vous êtes en permanence où
le sous la pression des associations
je préside le conseil des rivages je
suis vice président du conservatoire
depuis 40 ans j'en suis la mémoire on a
acheté 200 km de côtes
personne n'a jamais parlé mais dès qu'il
y à un élu quelconque qui veut élaborer
en plus bien entendu les associations ce
parti bille en tête évidemment je
préfère connaît la question mais que moi
il aura l'occasion de vous en parler
voilà je pourrais parler du pays
m'interroger je termine madame la
présidente je voudrais m'interroger
veille se termine dans un an on a
prolongé de deux mondes de deux ans mais
n'y aura plus d'argent après que fait on
que va être la situation économique
quand on sait que les travaux publics
seront amputés de 30 % de leur activité
voilà autant de questions qu'on pourrait
se poser on pourrait parler des heures
je conclus j'attends des réponses
je ne doute pas qu'elle soit aussi clair
que celle que vous avez livré à ajaccio
lors de votre récent voyage
elles nous permettront d'acter la
position du gouvernement vont réponse au
moment où s'engage la grande réforme
territoriale
demeure une interrogation
les institutions dans l'île s'est dotée
depuis 30 ans lui ont elles permis de
rentrer dans la modernité
de provoquer son propre auto development
si les contours financiers massifs de
l'état ont pu donner l'illusion que
notre retard social économique culturel
étaient comblés par rapport à la nation
trop de connivence
trop de complicité trop de non-dits trop
de refus d'assumer n'ont pas permis à la
société corse de se libérer d'elle-même
tous les progrès réalisés
quel qu'en soit le domaine tous les
changements de comportements auront été
accomplis par la société civile à
travers notamment la révolution
informatique depp est plus que par les
autorités publiques au moment où
s'engage une grande réforme territoriale
j'exprime le voeu que ne soit pas une
occasion manquée pour la corse qui vous
le savez monsieur le ministre
mérite sans doute mieux que la mauvaise
réputation dont on veut dire l'affligé
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues
dans la suite du débat la parole est à
notre collègue eliane giraud du groupe
socialiste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le débat
qui nous réunit ce soir porte sur la
corse et la réforme territoriale
il a été inscrit à l'ordre du jour du
sénat à la demande du groupe
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen et plus particulièrement à la
demande à votre demande monsieur le
sénateur nicolas alfonsi
le groupe socialiste et apparenté au nom
duquel intervient se félicite qu'un
débat consacré spécifiquement à la corse
ait lieu dans notre assemblée et vous
remercie chers collègues d'une donnée à
6 l'occasion de débattre de la réforme
territoriale en corse même si j'ai bien
compris ce qui vous importe s était bien
évidemment la réponse de ministres élus
de la montagne parlementaire de l'isère
vice-présidente de la région rhône alpes
je suis particulièrement sensible à la
beauté au charme de cette montagne posé
sur la mer qu'est la corse vice
présidente de la fédération des parcs
naturels régionaux j'admire la richesse
des paysages des territoires de la corse
et notamment ceux de ce merveilleux parc
naturel régional avec d'extraordinaire
réserve naturelle la réserve de
biosphère de la vallée du fango et la
réserve marine de terrain intéresse de
scandola avec bien sûr de formidables
révère réserve de biodiversité
la corse sentinelle avancée en
méditerranée méritent le soutien et
l'investissement de la france en
reconnaissance de ce qu'elle nous a
apporté tout au long de notre histoire
mais aussi pour son importance
stratégique en méditerranée hier
aujourd'hui et demain la corse nous
concerne tous ce débat s'inscrit dans
une actualité parlementaire riche sur la
réforme territoriale et ces deux projets
de loi le projet de loi relatif à la
délimitation des régions aux élections
régionales et départementales et
modifiant le calendrier électoral et le
projet de loi portant nouvelle
organisation territoriale de la
république présenté au nom du premier
ministre monsieur manuel valls à la
ministre de la décentralisation et de la
fonction publique madame marylise
lebranchu et le secrétaire d'état chargé
de la réforme territoriale monsieur
andré vallini que j'ai l'honneur de
remplacer au sénat depuis sa nomination
au gouvernement
et même si ma les ans au sénat est
récente je sais monsieur le sénateur
alfonsi votre engagement et votre
travail continue dans la vie publique je
tiens à rendre hommage à votre
conviction et à votre ouvrage défendant
en même temps l'unicité de la république
et la reconnaissance de la spécificité
et des singularités de la corse avec ce
débat en ce moment précis où notre pays
engagent une nécessaire réorganisation
territoriale vous montrer monsieur le
sénateur votre implication de
responsable politique soucieux de
l'avenir de la corse en apportant votre
vision pour les années à venir
le gouvernement de manuel valls comme
hier celui de jean marc ayrault et
particulièrement l écoute de la corse et
de ses habitants à la suite de
l'adoption le 27 septembre 2013 par
l'assemblée territoriale de corse d'une
délibération comprenant plusieurs points
une proposition de modification de la
constitution la mise en place d'une
gouvernance propre à la collectivité car
il te rial corse l'amélioration des
procédures d'adaptation car la
législation à la corse les modifications
au statut particulier de la corse les
ministes manuel valls et malgré dix de
branches qui ont rencontré à paris le 22
novembre 2013 une délégation de 14 élus
de corse
l'objectif de cette rencontre était de
les entendre des deux lentilles avec un
travail en commun sur l'amélioration du
fonctionnement des institutions
le 3 janvier dernier vrillé dernier
maryse lebranchu ajaccio a installé un
comité de travail sur l'organisation
territoriale de lille composé des
membres du comité stratégique de la ctc
et des représentants de l'état le 14
avril une seconde réunion a permis
d'échanger avec les membres du groupe de
travail sur l'apprentissage de la langue
corse avec au soutien apporté à la
création d'un établissement public
territorial les problèmes du foncier
avec la création par la loi allures d'un
établissement public foncier régional
qui permettra d'agir efficacement pour
augmenter l'offre de logements ou encore
la création d'une taxe ou redevance au
mouillage dans les réserves naturelles
et parc marin le 12 juin dernier
monsieur mise de l'intérieur vous vous
êtes rendu dans l'île de beauté pour
poursuivre le travail engagé et élaborer
des solutions efficaces
respectueuse du cadre constitutionnel
conforme aux attentes de nos concitoyens
corse et d élue ce travail conduit en
partenariat étroit avec les acteurs
concernés illustre bien la volonté du
gouvernement de donner toute leur place
aux élus de corse dans l'élaboration en
cours et la volonté de prendre la
problématique corse à bras le corps le
statut juridique de la corse a connu de
nombreuses réflexions et d'évolution
durant ces quarante dernières années
accroissant la montée en puissance des
responsabilités locales avec la loi du
30 juillet 80 de la corse devient une
collectivité territoriale de plein
exercice avec la loi du 13 mars 1991 de
nouvelles compétences et ressources
suisses ont transféré avec la loi du 22
juillet 2002 on amplifie le mouvement de
transfert avec de nouvelles
responsabilités des agents pour exercer
ses missions et du patrimoine depuis
2002 la double priorité de faciliter le
développement et de développer les
infrastructures de la corse est à
l'oeuvre cela notamment grâce aux
engagements pris au titre du programme
exceptionnel d'investissement n'y en a
pas lunel jospin que vous avez rappelé
c'est à dire 2 milliards d'euros
auxquels s'ajoutent 450 millions d'euros
au titre des financements européens qui
ont été mobilisés par ces
investissements importants la vie des
citoyens quotidien connu des
améliorations nombreuses dans leurs
déplacements au niveau de la qualité
l'accès de l'eau gestion des traitements
des déchets les équipements publics
comme vous l'indiquez monsieur le
ministre dans votre discours prononcé le
12 juin dernier la corse a connu la plus
forte croissance économique des régions
françaises sur ces dernières années dans
ce contexte il est important que les
efforts collectifs se poursuivent et
soit soutenu par le gouvernement et le
parlement les réflexions de pierre
chaubon le travail des élus corses et
les réformes institutionnelles voté par
l'assemblée de corse s'inscrivent dans
une dynamique positive en faisant
apparaître de nouvelles volontés
elles sont nombreuses le travail doit se
poursuivre pour parvenir à conforter
l'évolution de la corse et la volonté
des habitants dans le respect des
valeurs de la république sachant prendre
en compte et singularité de ce
territoire qu'il regroupement des
régions ne concerne pas la corse le
calendrier électoral lui la concerne la
première élection générale des
conseillers départementaux et des
membres de l'assemblée de corse suivant
la publication de cette loi se tiendra
au mois de décembre 2015 donnant suite
aux rapports préparés
pas la commission des compétences
législatives et réglementaires présidé
par monsieur pierre chaubon le projet de
loi relatif à l'organisation
territoriale de la république adoptée le
18 juin en conseil des ministres est
déposé sur le bureau du sénat du sénat
reprend plusieurs de ses propositions
nature à améliorer le fonctionnement des
institutions en continuant le processus
des gens engagés
de renforcement des responsabilités qui
sont déjà reconnus à la ctc ce faisant
le gouvernement a fait le choix d'une
réforme ciblée du statut législatif de
la ctc sur la base de recommandations de
l'assemblée de corse afin d'apposer
d'apporter une réponse immédiate aux
attentes des acteurs locaux je voudrais
citer par des parmi ces mesures la
précision facteur de simplification que
le droit commun applicable aux régions
s'applique à la corse afin qu'il ne soit
plus nécessaire de mentionner
spécifiquement la corse dans les autres
lois et règlements applicables aux
régions la possibilité donnée à
l'assemblée de corse de faciliter la
délégation à la commission permanente
afin d'introduire plus de souplesse dans
son fonctionnement et dans ses relations
avec le conseil exécutif la possibilité
de faire inscrire une question à l'ordre
du jour de l'assemblée à la demande d'un
cinquième de ses membres pour plus de
démocratie et de pluralisme
la modification des règles de
fonctionnement du conseil exécutif de
corse selon les préconisations du
rapport de septembre 2013 enfin la
programmation du plan exceptionnel
d'investissement ayant pris de retard il
est proposé de prolonger de deux ans la
mise en oeuvre de celui ci en accord
avec les partenaires locaux de la
convention cale ce pays qui résulte
d'une proposition du gouvernement
représentants élus de la corse formulée
à l'été 2000 a été consacrée par la loi
de janvier 2002 relative à la corse il
prévoit une programmation sur gazon
cazaux d'investissements publics
destinés à combler les retards
d'équipements dont souffrait la corse
dans plusieurs secteurs ces thèmes ne
manqueront pas d'être abordée par les
membres du comité stratégique de la
corse qui doit se tenir à la fin de la
semaine au 4 juillet en présence de la
ministre comme le sénateur comme vous la
vie de jim nicolas alfonsi est et comme
vous aimait à le répéter en reprenant
les propos de pierre mendès france votre
seule référence dites vous dans la vie
publique
un responsable ne se termine jamais dans
ses décisions par les conséquences
bonnes ou mauvaises qu'elles pourraient
avoir lui avoir pour lui mais en
fonction de l'intérêt général je crois
que c'est ce que nous faisons et c'est
ce que fait le gouvernement c'est cette
même logique qui doit toujours prévaloir
dans les rapports entre la france et la
corse je vous remercie de votre
attention merci chers collègues
la parole est à anne marie escoffier du
groupe rdse
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je n'aurais
pas je crois le même talent que mon ami
nicolas parce que même si j'ai quelques
racines corses je n'ai pas les mêmes
fondamentaux
insularité
marginalité voilà comment j'ai entendu
certains corps me présenter la corse à
l'occasion d'un déplacement
il y a près de 20 ans les choses ont
changé depuis l on ne peut que s'en
réjouir la corse est toujours aussi
belle les corses toujours aussi hors
norme à nous de mieux les comprendre de
mieux les entendre d'entendre ce qu'ils
sont ce que leur culture leur histoire
leur en donnait d'irremplaçable de
spécifique le déplacement que j'évoquais
il ya quelques secondes précédé la
promulgation de la loi du 13 mai 91
portant statut de la collectivité
territoriale de corse et faisant de
lille une collectivité territoriale à
statut particulier entrant dans le champ
de l'article 72 alinéa 1er de la
constitution
relatif aux collectivités territoriale à
statut particulier
depuis cette date la corse et les corses
ont trouvé progressivement un mode de
fonctionnement spécifique tout en
respectant le droit commun applicable
aux régions chaque fois que n'existe pas
de dérogation à ce droit ils ont
expérimenté une large responsabilité en
matière de compétences de leurs
collectivités beaucoup plus large que
les compétences transférées aux autres
régions du continent ils ont vécu avec
l'assemblée de corse et le
conseil-exécutif un mode de
fonctionnement nouveau qui a nécessité
une véritable capacité d'adaptation
un peu plus de vingt ans après cette
révolution au sens premier du mot après
cette réflexion au sens premier du mot
et ré organisation il n'était pas
illégitime que la corse s'interrogea sur
son fonctionnement elle le fait en
profitant de la réflexion globale sur la
réforme territoriale qui s'imposent à
notre pays la corse est comme le reste
de nos régions de nos départements de
nos territoires soumises au même constat
aux mêmes contraintes le redressement de
notre pays le développement de notre
économie le travail des jeunes et des
moins jeunes le besoin absolu de
sécurité
mais toutes ces attentes dans un
contexte compliqué il faut l'admettre
par les problématiques liées à
l'insularité les déplacements leurs
coûts les délais les approvisionnements
le tourisme le respect de
l'environnement l'agriculture
autant d'exemples qui développe
montrerai bien la spécificité de l'île
je voudrais ici n'aborder que deux
problématiques de la réforme
territoriale d'abord et de la sécurité
très rapidement ensuite je veux saluer
la disponibilité les coudes du
gouvernement de celui ci et du précédent
qui sont allés à la rencontre des élus
de corse pour entend leurs besoins leur
apporter une réponse et je crois
monsieur le préfet je peux en témoigner
pour m'être déplacé à vos côtés n'y a
pas si longtemps que ça je sais fort
bien que ni marylise lebranchu
ni manuel valls alors ministre de
l'intérieur ni vous même monsieur le
ministre n'avait ménagé votre peine le
projet de loi portant nouvelle
organisation territoriale delà de la
république consacre son article 13 à la
corse il nous reviendra cher collègue à
l'automne
d'examiner ce texte et je n'en
disconviens pas de lui apporter des
améliorations comme on le fait ici
régulièrement je veux néanmoins souligné
que ce texte est le fruit de nombreux
débats de nombreuses rencontres et notre
collègue madame giraud les a rappelé il
ya un instant né des propositions du
rapport établi par la commission des
compétences législatives et
réglementaires sur les institutions
particulière de la corse présenté à
l'aaas ans à la session de l'assemblée
de corse de fin septembre 2013
chacun s'était accordé alors à
reconnaître la nécessité de remédier à
des dysfonctionnements
susceptibles d'entraver le bon
fonctionnement de l'assemblée de corse à
ce titre le projet de texte prévoit
quatre mesures principales qui ont été
dites dit tout à l'heure et que je
reprends très rapidement à mon compte
l'affirmation de l'applicabilité à la
corse de toutes les dispositions
législatives propre aux régions non
contraires à celles spécifiques à la
collectivité territoriale de corse c'est
une mesure de simplification tout
simplement dans le texte dit permet une
applicabilité
simplifiée sans avoir à reprendre
d'autres textes ni par la loi ni par le
règlement la possibilité en deuxième
temps donné à l'assemblée de corse de
modifier la liste des compétences
déléguées à sa commission permanente en
cours de mandat c'est une flexibilité
opportunément reconnu aux membres de
l'assemblée qui en ont émis le voeux et
qui montrait quelques embarras que l'on
a connu le troisième point
l'organisation rendu possible du retour
à l'assemblée de corse de l'ensemble des
membres du conseil exécutif
président y compris en cas de démission
sous réserve qu'il s'agisse d'une
démission collective
ou du vote d'une motion de défiance
cette motion de défiance relevant d'un
mécanisme original
al de responsabilité politique de
l'exécutif devant l'assemblée de corse
dernière mesure dont a parlé longuement
d'ailleurs mon collègue nicolas alfonsi
le prolongement de deux ans du programme
exceptionnel d'investissement pour la
corse programme dont il faut se
féliciter qui avait été fixée pour une
durée de 15 ans personne ne leur mettra
en cause simplement il avait été
retardée interrompu d'où la nécessité de
le prolonger et je ne peux avec nicolas
alfonsi que m'inquiéter de ce qui
adviendra une fois le programme terminé
à à l'issue de ces deux années monsieur
le ministre je sais moi aussi pour avoir
lu votre discours ne pas l'avoir entendu
mais l'avoir lu votre accord de principe
sur le texte qui va être proposé dans
quelques mois je sais aussi votre
volonté s'il le fallait
d'aller plus loin pour aller vers un
consensus fort et durable
sa part ça fait partie intégrante de
votre façon d'être de votre façon de
faire et on ne peut que le saluer mais
il s'agit d'un consensus qui n'a pas
besoin du mois du moins me semble-t-il à
moi et je crois que la question vous a
été posée tout à l'heure d'une révision
de la constitution en est il besoin mais
il faut qu'il s'agit d'un consensus
respectueux de notre droit national est
de notre droit européen et ça a été dit
d'ailleurs à l'occasion de quelques
dispositions qui avait été souhaitée par
quelques élus corses un consensus encore
respectueux du triple principe que nous
connaissons bien d'unités de la
république de prise en compte de sa
diversité et cela dans le cadre de sa
spécificité et pour la corse ça s'impose
et troisième principe de subsidiarité
ce triple principe que vous connaissez
bien que nous avons choisi appliqué au
reste du territoire et nous l'avons fait
notamment dans le cadre de la loi du 27
janvier 2014 de modernisation de
l'action publique et d'infirmation du
territoire triple principe d'unité de la
république de diversité des territoires
et de subsidiarité
le ministre un mot au delà de cette
réforme
territoriale qui sera appliqué à la
corse avec je crois à la juste mesure
qu'il faut je voudrais ajouter un mot
concernant la problématique sécuritaire
qu'elle soit déclinée dans s'agissant de
l'organisation de la police et de la
gendarmerie que des sapeurs pompiers
dans les deux cas il s'agit de la
protection des personnes et des biens et
je voudrais comme vous l'avez fait à
votre suite simplement comme vous
l'avait fait lors de votre déplacement
en corse le 12 juin dernier ça lui le
dévouement la disponibilité le courage
de nos forces de sécurité qui
travaillent côte à côte au risque de
leur vie au quotidien et qui n'hésite
pas à s'exposer simplement simplement
pour faire leurs devoirs parce que c'est
leur devoir qui s'imposent à eux comme
beaucoup d'entre nous monsieur le
ministre je ne peux ici que formé le
voeu que
l'engagement d'apaisement que j'ai
entendu de la part de certaines factions
se concrétise qu'il se concrétise vite
et en totalité que de drames alors
éviter que de tensions apaisées que la
corse sera belle d'une harmonie
retrouvée
merci chers collègues
la parole est à ronan dantec du groupe
écologiste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre chers collègues je voudrais
tout d'abord remercier le sénateur
nicolas alfonsi le groupe rdse pour
avoir inscrit à l'ordre du jour ce débat
sur l'avenir de la corse vue à travers
les chroniques de faits divers la corse
apparaît généralement comme un
territoire à problèmes une terre de
violence atavique mais aussi un des
symboles d impuissance de l'état je ne
partage évidemment pas ce point de vue
je considère que par bien des aspects la
corse peut même devenir un laboratoire
d'excellence pour construire de
nouvelles modernité territoriales à
condition de se dégager des
conservatismes et des dogmes
idéologiques la corse mérite mieux qu'un
terrain d'affrontement entre
nationalisme entre droit à
l'autodétermination républicanisme
sourcilleux affrontement sans fin qui
empêche de forger des réponses réelles à
des questions concrètes de difficultés
de vie quotidienne il est dans la nature
des écologistes de tourner le dos à ces
exacerbation qui cassent souvent des
intérêts particuliers pour s'attaquer
aux enjeux réels et dans les quelques
minutes qui me sont impartis je voudrais
en décliner 3 l'enjeu environnemental
tout d'abord dans un bassin
méditerranéen et ça a été dit avant moi
dont le littoral a été sacrifié au
tourisme de masse la société corse et il
faut ici lui rendre hommage à mieux
préserver ses paysages que tout autre
territoire de la sardaigne au
languedoc-roussillon nous devons le
remercier et la soutenir dans l'adoption
d'un pas du plan d'aménagement et de
développement durable de la corse
ambitieux qui devra préserver une part
de cette beauté du monde d'un patrimoine
qui participent de l'enchantement
collectif ce qui signifie aussi répondre
à un certain nombre d'enjeux sociaux
nous y reviendrons dans le domaine
environnemental toujours je considère
que la corse peut être une des vitrines
territoriale de la transition
énergétique
elle a les atouts de la révolution des
énergies renouvelables l'eau le soleil
le vent la biomasse
avec par exemple le projet d'areva la
corse accueille déjà des
expérimentations prometteuses en matière
de stockage d'énergie mais il manque
encore de la volonté politique pour
franchir un cap il faut un pilotage fin
par les nouvelles technologies des
réseaux intelligents de ce potentiel
considérable en énergies renouvelables
pour en gérer la variabilité il faut des
investissements résolu et cohérent il
faut ici monsieur le ministre arrêter de
tergiverser et il est de la
responsabilité de l'état d'imposer à son
opérateur historique de ne plus
considérer la corse comme un territoire
juste bons à brûler des fuels lourds
dont plus personne ne veut dans le
domaine de la langue la corse est aussi
en avance puisque elle a réussi à mieux
préserver sa langue que bien d'autres
territoires en france et en europe la
volonté de reconquête linguistique porté
par l'assemblée de corse et donc à
soutenir tant la france chantre dans les
conférences internationales d'une
diversité culturelle parfois limité à la
défense de la francophonie est ici
fragilisé dans sa crédibilité
internationale par son incapacité à
faire vivre sur son sol sa propre
diversité linguistique au delà des
vielles lunes jacobine d'une france
menacée par ses propres territoires le
projet de co officialité de la langue
corse est au contraire une véritable
opportunité à saisir pour nour décrivit
recrédibiliser dans le monde alors que
la france et ça a été dit avant moi n'a
toujours pas ratifié la charte
européenne des langues minoritaires
malgré les engagements de campagne du
président hollande après votre visite en
corse monsieur le ministre ma question
sera ici extrêmement précise qu'elles
sont donc du point de vue de l'état au
delà des postures idéologiques
les éléments de la proposition de koffi
sial it est adoptée par l'ensemble et de
corse qui nécessiterait d'être amendée
pour permettre à l'état de soutenir
cette proposition
voilà une question simple troisième
point monsieur le ministre le débat sur
le statut de résidents dont on a aussi
parlé nicolas alfonsi les instances
locales d'europe écologie les verts en
corse ont clairement dit que nous
considérons qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une
bonne réponse un vrai problème celui de
la difficulté des habitants de l'île à
se loger du fait de la pression
touristique sur le prix du logement nous
considérons d'abord de m'en sortir la
corse de sa spécialisation dans une mono
industrie touristique qui la déstabilise
produit des emplois précaires et peu
qualifiés et entraîne une pression
insoutenable sur le foncier le littoral
les deux facteurs se combinent pour une
crise du logement engendrés par l'écart
entre ce revenu moyen faible des
résidents permanents et le prix de
l'immobilier conditionné lui par des
acheteurs est extérieur souvent plus
fortunés nous devons donc agir et
d'abord par le soutien à de nouveaux
secteurs économiques la transition
énergétique encore par exemple pour l
opportunité de création d'emplois
durables et qualifiés notamment dans le
secteur solaire ensuite il faut trouver
absolument des réponses pour stopper la
spéculation immobilière et garantir
l'accès au logement
les écologistes ont fait plusieurs
propositions en ce sens étendre la loi
duflot pour encadrer les loyers dans
certaines zones touristiques
plafonner le taux de résidences
secondaires sont des propositions
concrètes et facile à mettre en oeuvre
monsieur le ministre l'a aussi ma
question sera simple au-delà du
caractère très probablement
anticonstitutionnel du statut de
résident votre gouvernement serait-il
favorables à mettre en oeuvre ces
propositions pour faciliter l'accès des
habitants de l'île un logement à coût
maîtrisé c'est une question centrale
pour l'avenir de la corse un statut de
résident qui se fonderait sur un droite
du sang telles que le débat actuel
laisse entrevoir n'entre pas dans les
valeurs de l'écologie politique
s'il ne nous sommes pas favorables au
statut tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
présente est liée à la question d'accès
à la propriété nous sommes en revanche
favorable à une citoyenneté de résidence
ce sont aussi ces questions qui sont
posées par le débat corse approfondir
l'idée d'une citoyenneté d'une
citoyenneté corse de résidence seraient
affirmé cette notion de communauté de
destin s'éloigner d'un système
clientéliste qui instrumentalisent le
vote des propriétaires de résidences
secondaires et affirmer ainsi les droits
des résidents permanents dont les
étrangers résidant et travaillant en
corse à travers ce débat aujourd'hui ne
s'agit donc pas de se lamenter ou de
crainte que des réponses corse ne
détricote de la république il s'agit au
contraire de soutenir en corse des
propositions et réponses adaptées aux
enjeux d'aujourd'hui
et de demain d'accompagner résolument
des politiques publiques modernes au
service d'un territoire qui fut parfois
en avance sur son temps merci merci
chers collègues la parole est à colette
giudicelli du groupe ump
madame la présidente monsieur ministre
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs en
février dernier madame lebranchu
mussolini elle il est chargé de la
décentralisation à sale et ajaccio un
groupe de travail sur la réforme
institutionnelle à l'égard de la corse
elle parlait alors de réformer
l'organisation de lille à trois niveaux
réglementaire législatif et même
constitutionnel sur ce point elle
indiqué en effet aux élus corses que la
porte n'était pas fermée en avril lors
d'une seconde réunion du groupe de
travail
madame la ministre confirme et je cite
sa volonté d'avancer sur ce chantier de
la réforme institutionnelle
allant même jusqu'à donner au nom du
gouvernement un avis favorable ce sont
ces propos la plupart des demandes
faites par l'assemblée de corse
ces déclarations ont fait réagir pour
des raisons contraire bien sûr les
partisans d'une scission nationalistes
comme les ait pu les élus républicains
que nous sommes car derrière la demande
d'une place spécifique à la corse dans
la constitution de la république
soutenue par la majorité de l'assemblée
de corse certains sont allés jusqu'à
évoquer la confidentialité de la langue
la création d'un statut de résident ou
l'autonomie de gestion en matière
fiscale autant de pistes qui ont créé un
débat parmi les élus corses de la
société civile et aujourd'hui encore
peut-être est-ce la raison pour laquelle
deux mois seulement après les
déclarations de madame lebranchu vous
avez décidé monsieur lounis des fermé la
porte à toute évolution institutionnelle
en corse nous l'avait justifié le 12
juin dernier lors de votre visite sur
place concerne le souci de préserver une
spécificité ne doit pas s'inscrire dans
une démarche de rupture il nous sommes
d'accord avec ce que vous avez dit et il
nous sommes d'accord avec vous personne
ne peut s'offusquer que l'on rappelle le
sacro saint principe de notre république
une et indivisible qui est d'apporter
mon absence de justice d'égalité de
liberté de fraternité à l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens
pour autant me semble que votre annonce
ne saurait suffire elle ne saurait
suffire car elle referme brutalement le
lit du processus de réflexion et de
dialogue engagé jusqu'ici par les élus
corses aux côtés de la population comme
si tout allait bien il suffit de
regarder les indicateurs économiques
sans parler des actes de violence que
les médias évoquent bien assez bien trop
pour savoir que l'hôtel n'est pas le cas
malheureusement plus inquiétant encore
votre annonce et nous le regrettons
créer de la désillusion que le terreau
du ressentiment en rayon en raison d'un
mollet discussions engagées justice hits
comme si elle n'avait qu aucun intérêt
vous décevez peut-être malheureusement
une population corse attaché à la parole
donnée vous reprenez cette parole la
déception est à la mesure de l'espoir
suscité
espoirs dans la corse a pourtant besoin
au même titre que tous nos compatriotes
on repense alors à la mise en garde du
député laurent marc angel qui disait
nous devons cesser de susciter de faux
espoirs pour ne travailler que sur du
possible il ya donc un monde mais ce
ministre entre la rupture que vous
râlerez rebuter a raison et la fin de
non-recevoir peut vous sembler opposés
et qui nous semble à tour c'est une
belle occasion nantes est de montrer la
force comme à toutes nos régions que la
france est capable d'évoluer de se
réinventer en restant le pays qu'elle a
toujours été riche de ses particularités
régionales et de ses cultures
entremêlées depuis l'antiquité ironie de
l'histoire c'est justement cette corse
il faut que vous entendiez qui fait
souvent la première en europe à l'époux
de la démocratie de sa constitution 1755
adoptant la séparation des pouvoirs le
suffrage universel et monsieur le
ministre vous savez qu'à donner le droit
de vote aux femmes en
1755 nous on a fallu attendre 180 devant
le général de gaulle vient nous faire le
même cadeau les en 1944
c'était pour vous faire sourire et de sa
aux dispositions statutaires
particulière avec la
bidépartementalisation et la naissance
de l'assemblée de corse où
il a toujours pris sa part dans la
concertation comme en 2003 ou sous
l'impulsion du premier ministre jean
pierre raffarin souhaitant déjà intégré
la reconnaissance institutionnelle de sa
spécificité la population corse a été
consulté rappelant à cette occasion que
la corse c'est la france raison de plus
pour l'écouté aujourd'hui ainsi que l'a
si bien dit camille de rocca gère notre
rôle n'est pas de freiner toute
évolution qui pourrait être bénéfique à
la corse mais bien de promouvoir une
démarche qui soit utile pour humaine
dans le respect de notre appartenance et
dans notre attachement à la république
plus que jamais nos territoires ont
besoin que l'on sauvegarde leur identité
leur patrimoine que l'on respecte la
richesse de leur diversité plus que
jamais ils ont le droit d'exister de
transmettre leur histoire et leur
culture aux jeunes générations
toujours dans la maison france car
chacun grandi auprès de l'osce et
territoires ont apporté à la france
comme la france leur a apporté refuser
de regarder l'histoire en face c'est
souvent refusé de se tourner vers
l'avenir plus encore dans le cas de la
corse puisque parallèlement elle va
subir vous le savez monsieur le ministre
on beaucoup d'autres régions la réforme
territoriale
celle ci pourrait même lui être fatale
parce qu'en raison de ses spécificités
insulaires la porsche ne bénéficiera pas
delvienne qu alisation dont disposeront
les grandes régions avec la disparition
programmée des départements
elle ne gardera pas non plus
l'opportunité que ce soit de ces à ses
arbitrages financiers relatifs à la
péréquation qui sont si importants pour
l'activité économique de l'île à une
époque où l'on supprime les départements
où on affaiblit les cantons ruraux ce
nouvel épisode concernant la corse est
important à double titre il est
important pour les ports ce même bien
sûr pour la défense de leur héritage et
de leurs particularités
il est surtout il est aussi et surtout
crucial pour notre pays la corse dans la
france est un symbole pour moi en tout
cas celui de la préservation de notre
identité millénaire
indivisible mais pluriel aussi il pour
vous expliquer plus en détails que vous
expliquer plus en détails de votre
déclaration du bouchon un dernier encore
sur cette terre de vos ancêtres monsieur
nuit j'aimerais que vous précisiez je
vous demande si vous pouvez nous précise
amy sioniste la position réelle du
gouvernement sur la question
institutionnelle de la corse au delà de
la réforme territoriale que vous devez
nous présenter je vous remercie je
voudrais remercier aussi initiales font
si d'avoir pris l'initiative de ce débat
et qui nous a qui nous séduit parce que
nous aimons touche beaucoup la corse
merci chers collègues
la parole est à jean-jacques la sphère
du groupe u10 uc
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je tiens
tout d'abord à remercier monsieur de si
intéressant si son groupe d'avoir
proposé ce débat ont regardé réforme
territoriale qui se prépare et de
l'histoire particulière de la corse
l'intérêt semble plus qu évident
par ailleurs ce débat suscite
personnellement propres intérêts pour
une autre raison sont possibles
rapprochements à certains égards avec un
débat sur la collectivité basque qui
m'est chère tout aussi particulière tout
aussi sujettes à des discussions
ces compétences sont moins de
gouvernance les points communs entre les
deux sont nombreux
malheureusement pays basque ce dernier
constat de d'embryons par rapport à la
corse il est bien difficile de lui faire
prendre forme les obstacles étaient
nombreux le gouvernement ne contredira
pas sur ce point m dans la perspective
d'une évolution future de l'organisation
de nos territoires qui reste à décider
ils conviennent de nous concerter
d'entendre les arguments des uns et des
autres sans conservatisme primaire sans
non plus un réformisme berne la corse
est aujourd'hui un territoire
particulier particulier de par son
histoire rattaché d'abord à la
république de gênes avant de se
proclamer indépendante en 1735 et enfin
rattachée à la france l'histoire est
toujours nécessaire pour rappeler qu'il
existe des liens singuliers entre la
république et la corse et qui ont
justifié la création d'un statut spécial
en effet la corse est la seule
collectivité territoriale à statut
particulier au sens de l'article 72
alinéa 1 de notre constitution
les revendications vertus d'autonomie ou
vers plus d'indépendance de lille on a
assurément contribué à cette singularité
la loi du 2 mars 82 pourtant statut de
la région de corse créé l'assemblée de
corse qui dispose de larges compétences
ce statut avant gardiste perdra cette
avance si on peut dire avec d'une part
l'alignement sur les autres régions
seront fonctionnement semblable à celui
de la corse et d'autre part avec la
réintégration de la corse dans le droit
commun électoral avec l'abandon de la
pour sionnel pour l'élection de
l'assemblée de corse néanmoins c'est la
loi du 13 mai 81 11 qui crée la
collectivité territoriale de corse et
qui fait de lille une collectivité
territoriale à statut particulier c'est
un modèle unique une structure juridique
administrative sur mesure qui fut créée
par cette loi ce n'était pourtant que la
première étape la loi du 22 janvier 2002
ceci a été rappelée relatives à la corse
va être source de nouveautés
institutionnels parmi lesquelles le
transfert de nouvelles compétences une
partie du statut fiscal et les
dispositions sur la langue corse
aujourd'hui le projet de loi relatif à
la nouvelle organisation de la
république consacre un chapitre à la
corse il ya selon moi deux enjeux
majeurs le premier est d'assurer le
développement de la corse en tenant
compte de sa culture et de son
insularité vous l'avez compris nous
sommes je suis personnellement très
attachée à la reconnaissance de la
spécificité culturelle des territoires
le deuxième est de garantir une certaine
cohérence économique en effet l'esprit
de la réforme est de fusionner des
régions pour permettre une logique de
développement économique mutuelle je ne
peux que partager cette volonté
néanmoins le découpage de proposer peut
créer des régions à deux vitesses est
face à deux grandes régions forte
économiquement il est nécessaire et que
lille dispose enfin de moyens
nécessaires dans le projet de loi des
mesures sont proposées l'objectif est
d'améliorer le fonctionnement
institutionnel de la collectivité parmi
lesquelles l'application à la corse de
toutes les dispositions législatives
relatives aux régions dès lors qu'elles
ne sont pas contraires à celles qui
régissent la collectivité territoriale
de corse ou encore la prorogation du
programme exceptionnel d'investissement
pour la corse près de 2 milliards
d'euros ont été mobilisés en dix ans
pour assurer la pérennité économique de
l'île ceci a été rappelé et ces
investissements ont produit des
résultats exceptionnels une forte
croissance économique de près de 2 et
demi pour cent par an et qui dépasse
bien entendu beaucoup d'autres régions
je le disais la singularité de la corse
est reconnue doit être reconnu cette
singularité doit s'inscrire dans la loi
la loi de la république doit s'adapter
aux singularités territoriale
l'assemblée de corse dans une
délibération de septembre 2013 a formulé
des souhaits pour le futur
institutionnel de lille l'assemblée a
demandé l'inscription de la corse dans
la constitution la co officialité de la
langue corse le statut de résident je
partage certaines journalistes qui
viennent d'être qui vient d'être évoqué
ces mesures rencontre bien entendu des
difficultés tant au niveau du droit
interne que du droit européen
ces mesures ont une portée symbolique
elle mérite tout d'être traitées les
questions qui nous sont imposées doivent
être entendus et traités première
question peut-on rendre compatible de
revendications régionalistes et les
principes républicains
les principes républicains auxquels nous
sommes tous attachés ne craignons pas de
répondre par l'affirmative
l'histoire démontre que la surdité des
états à la 2e aux demandes spécifiques
sous couvert de respect des principes
républicains
cette surdité confort de ceux trop
souvent les revendications nationalistes
dans leurs excès notre devoir est
d'affirmer un certes les principes
républicains mais également d'aménager
l'ajout de la loi chaque fois que dans
ce cadre là chaque fois que cela est
possible dans le domaine de la langue de
la culture du développement économique
de l'aménagement territorial les
spécificités doivent pouvoir se
retrouver dans les modes de gouvernance
deuxième question l'attitude par rapport
à la violence une règle me semble-t-il
devrait être de mise ne jamais rejeter
les perspectives de dialogue en
réaffirmant les obligations
républicaines certes mais en manifestant
dans le respect la volonté de dialoguer
troisième question le débat qui va
s'engager sur la réforme territoriale le
sera-t-il suffisamment de place aux
expressions régionalistes monsieur le
ministre l'égalité ne veut pas dire
forcément l'une l'uniformité les
discours sur l'égalité sont
malheureusement trop souvent
simplificateur et ceci parfois afin
d'éviter les questions complexes
personne ne conteste d'égalité devant
les droits fondamentaux et j'espère que
le débat sur la réforme territoriale
nous permettra de poser les questions
des spécificités régionales
les basques les bretons les corses ce
débat nous permettra d'être suffisamment
créatif pour traiter au cas par cas des
modèles de gouvernance adaptée et
responsabilisant nous espérons également
que ce débat permettra de nous rendre
artisan de l'apaisement d'abord par l'
écoute par le traitement de tous les
dossiers préoccupants avec l'ensemble je
dis bien l'ensemble des partenaires
selon m
merci chers collègues dernier
intervenant inscrits dans ce débat le
président thierry foucaud du groupe crc
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues notre débat
de ce soir bien qu'il porte sur un point
spécifique et particuliers je pense doit
nous interroger sur la cohérence et la
logique qui anime cette réforme
territoriale dont l'examen du premier
volet était prévu discussions demain
après midi en effet nous devions aborder
demain une réorganisation territoriale
de la république mais en commençant à
l'envers à l'envers car contrairement à
toute logique il était prévu que nous
commencions par le plus délicat le plus
compliqué le plus sensible une nouvelle
délimitation du périmètre des régions
donc pour reprendre l'expression de
claudy lebreton on ne comprend pas des
critères objectifs
à la suite de ce raid redécoupage
territorial
nous discuterons plus tard à une période
un terrain déterminé en raison du fort
mécontentement que provoquent les
modalités de votre réforme monsieur le
ministre du contenu de ces coquille
encore vide que seront les nouvelles
régions je veux dire par là que ce n'est
qu'ultérieurement que nous serons amenés
à modifier la répartition des
responsabilités et des compétences entre
les régions nouvellement créée et les
départements départements qui seront
vidés de leur substance et qui à terme
court le risque d'être rendus inutiles
ainsi ce soir nous anticipons nous
dépasse nous débattons d'un point tout à
fait particulier au sein de la réforme
les futures compétences de la région
corse dont la collectivité territoriale
a d'ailleurs échappé aux effets d'un big
bang qui prétend clarifier simplifier
les relations en chacun des acteurs de
la puissance publique
après tout la corse aurait pu comme
d'autres est trop regroupés de façon
improbable avec la région province alpes
côte d'azur elle a sans doute échappé à
ce big band car comme dans toutes les
régions à forte identité je pense à
l'alsace à la bretagne ce qui touche aux
rapports avec la république est sensible
du fait sans doute de la susceptibilité
je dirais diverses qu'il faut veiller à
ne pas froisser dans le projet de loi
portant nouvelle organisation
territoriale de la république un volet
plus précisément l'article 13 est donc
consacrée à la collectivité territoriale
de corse cet article procède aux
ajustements rendus nécessaires par le
renforcement des responsabilités et
régionales et l'éventuelle suppression
des deux départements
social notre avis doit se faire dans le
respect du statut actuel de la corse et
n'avoir pour seul objectif que
d'améliorer le fonctionnement du
dispositif existant à cet égard dans le
cadre des discussions et des
consultations qui doivent
obligatoirement être effectués près à
blom préalablement à l'élaboration du
projet de loi l'assemblée territoriale
de corse a fait part de ses remarques au
gouvernement dans une délibération
adoptée le 31 mars dernier je ne
commenterai par le détail de ces
remarques ni ce qui en a été retenu dans
l'article 13 nous aurons l'occasion
d'avoir un débat approfondi sur le sujet
lorsque ce texte viendra en discussion à
l'automne peut-être nous dirons alors
notre opposition à la suppression
programmée de ces échelon de proximité
que constituent les départements en
revanche plus généralement je voudrais
faire part de l'appréciation de mon
groupe sur certaines prises de position
récentes qui ont alimenté le débat
monsieur le ministre le 13 juin dernier
lors de votre visite sur l'île
vous avez eu l'occasion de faire le
point sur la poursuite des discussions
sur ces sujets et surtout de vous
prononcer sur quelques réformes de
nature institutionnelle
voté par l'assemblée de corse je
voudrais dire d'emblée qu'il serait
inopportun comme le souhaitent certains
de saisir cette occasion pour faire
dériver la discussion du projet de loi
sur la nouvelle organisation
territoriale de la république entend
temps d'entamer des négociations sur un
nouveau statut pour la corse j'aurais
peut-être qu'à nos yeux il s'agit bien
d'un rester à la volonté d'améliorer le
fonctionnement du dispositif actuel et
non d'ouvrir la voie à des évolutions
institutionnelles
qui sont nous pensons d'une autre nature
je pense très précisément transfert de
la compétence fiscale au statut de co
officialité de la langue corse et à la
question foncière à laquelle il est
répondu par un statut de résident je
dirais d'une dangereuse ambiguïté autant
de sujets qui soulève des questions qui
n'entre pas dans le cadre de la réforme
territoriale qui fait l'objet de ce
projet de loi en évoquant ces questions
je ne pense pas m'éloigner du sujet qui
nous occupe ce soir il me semble en
effet que ces dernières semaines le
thème de l'évolution du statut de la
corse a de nouveau fait irruption dans
le débat public sur l'île j'en vois par
exemple au pour preuve la façon dont un
mouvement indépendantiste en perte de
vitesse ayant depuis longtemps glissé je
dirais vers un affairisme douteux a
tenté d'expliquer pourquoi il mettait
fin à ses activités terroristes
en effet évoquant deux récents votes à
l'assemblée de corse le flnc
a estimé que la majorité des élus
rejoignaient sur ses thèmes ses propres
sources doctrinal nom à l'instar du
président de l'assemblée de corse mon
ami dominique bucchini j'estime que ce
n'est pas par ce biais que seront
traités les problèmes réels de la corse
et de sa population
ces problèmes ce sont entre autres le
développement économique des conditions
sociales le chômage le foncier peut-être
mais je dirais sous un autre aspect au
total nous souhaitons vivement que
l'ensemble de ces questions soit
positivement évoqué le moment venu la de
la discussion du projet de loi nous
souhaitons enfin que la prochaine
rencontre sur place avec les élus de
votre collègue au gouvernement
madame lebranchu puisse contribuer par
le dialogue à corriger certains aspects
négatifs de la réforme tels sont
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
dans le cas de ce débat sur la corse et
la réforme territoriale
quelques appréciations dont le groupe
crc souhaitez vous faire part
merci monsieur le président foucault
dans la suite fin du débat la parole est
bien évidemment monsieur bernard
cazeneuve ministre de l'intérieur vous
avez la parole monsieur le ministre
mais là la présidente madame et
messieurs les sénateurs je voudrais
avant tout remercier le sénateur nicolas
alfonsi pour avoir organisé ce débat
qui lui tenait à coeur et qui était pour
lui l'occasion d'aborder tous les sujets
concernant l'avenir de l'île non
seulement les aspects institutionnels
des aspects constitutionnels qu'il a
pris le soin de distinguer
méticuleusement dans son propos à juste
titre par esprit de rigueur juridique
mais également d'aborder d'autres sujets
que certains d'entre vous ont évoqué
dans leurs propos
je dirais même que chacun d'entre vous a
évoqué dans son propos et qui concerne
les préoccupations que les corps sont
immédiatement à l'esprit lorsqu'il
s'agit d'assurer le développement de
leur île et qui concerne la question du
logement la question de la spéculation
et de la pression foncière la question
des investissements
auxquels les territoires aspire toujours
lorsqu'il s'agit de créer les conditions
de la croissance et de l'emploi j'ai
bien madame la sénatrice
entendu les préoccupations qui sont les
vôtres votre propos teintés de
satisfaction d'avoir vu le gouvernement
procédait à des clarifications et
d'insatisfaction et d'impatience parce
que vous auriez souhaité que le propos
pu aller plus loin mais la politique est
un exercice itératif et les débats
parlementaires sont là pour préciser des
choses qui ne l'ont pas été même si
j'avais le sentiment d'en avoir déjà
beaucoup dit mais puisque nous sommes
ensemble ce soir c'est pour moi
l'occasion de répondre à toutes les
interrogations et de préciser la pensée
et et de le faire avec la même sincérité
que celle que j'ai voulu mettre dans le
propos que j'ai tenus en corse il ya de
cela quelques semaines le premier point
sur lequel je voudrais
assister c'est sur la nécessité en
politique si l'on ne veut pas que les
choses soient abaissées de respecter
ceux auxquels on s'adresse en toutes
circonstances
et respectez ceux auxquels on s'adresse
ce est convoquée comme le disait nicolas
alfonsi à l'instant l'esprit de pierre
mendès france
l'esprit de ces grands républicains qui
surent faire preuve de modernité qui
furent souvent en situation alors que
loris l'histoire lors été parfois
hostile de poser les ventes le fondement
d'évolution pertinentes et heureuse mais
de le faire toujours avec une exigence
de rigueur intellectuelle
de le faire toujours en ayant convoqué
le droit lorsqu'il s'agit d'enjeux
juridique est convoqué le droit ça veut
dire le palau tordre ce que ledroit
n'aime pas être tordu comme son nom
l'indiqué pour atteindre des objectifs
politiques
mais d'essayer de mettre le droit au
service d'objectifs politiques lorsqu'on
estime qu'ils sont nobles et lorsqu'il
ya des désaccords de pouvoir les
exprimer ça veut dire aussi ne pas tout
sacrifier aux charmes de la politique je
ne dis pas que cela est le cas en corse
je dis que c'est une prévention qu'il
faut avoir en toutes matières
car la politique a ses charmes auquel il
est facile de céder mais les charmes de
la politique et la rigueur
intellectuelle ce n'est pas
nécessairement le même sujet ça peut
l'être et ça ne l'est pas nécessairement
enfin il ya une nécessité aussi de faire
en sorte que le discours selon eux mêmes
quels que soient les lieux
car ce serait quand même pour moi très
confortable d'aller dire à jacques sur
des choses que les corses serait censé
avoir envie d'entendre et de dire à
paris des choses que la représentation
nationale pourrait souhaiter écouter
sans me préoccuper de savoir si le
discours serait le même à paris et
ajaccio moi j'aime bien tenir le m
partout parce que c'est aussi une
condition du respect que l'on doit aux
interlocuteurs auxquels on s'adresse
enfin je voudrais insister
sur le fait que le sujet que nous
évoquons ce soir je l' ai senti comme un
élément sous-jacent de tous les discours
qui sont elles qui ont été tenus est un
débat ancien comme la république elle
même et comme la construction de la
nation en france a pu l'être puisque
nous vivons dans un pays particulier où
l'état pour exister à la nation et où la
nation s'est incarné dans l'état et où
il faut reconnaître que le processus
historique de création de l'état et
d'incarnation de la nation dans l'état
s'est fait à partir d'un processus de
centralisation
où l'on a vu le droit
organiser les choses de telle manière
que une langue s'imposer des principes
de droit convoquant souvent pour ne pas
dire toujours l'égalité s'incarner dans
des textes votés par la représentation
nationale est la question qui nous est
posée c'est celle de la compatibilité
entre la république tel que nous
l'aimons une et indivisible et la
diversité de ses territoires de ces
cultures de ces approches que la
république ne doit pas annihiler que la
république ne doit pas empêcher que la
république ne doit pas obérer mais que
précisément la république doit rendre
possible précisément parce que son unité
son indivisibilité est aussi la garantie
qu'en son sein
chacun pourra trouver son chemin sans
que le principe de l'égalité devant le
droit devant la charge publique qui sont
des principes consubstantielle à la
république elle-même ne soit remise en
cause voilà donc le sujet qui nous est
posée comment rendre tout cela
compatibles en droit et en politique et
comment le faire dans un contexte qui
laissait la corse toute sa chance
sans faire perdre à la république ses
principes et ses atouts voilà le
problème tel que je le vois je nie pas
que c'est un problème ça je ne dis pas
non plus que c'est un problème
insurmontable
je pense qu'il existe en toute chose en
politique dès lors qu'il y ait de là une
fois de la rigueur et de l'honnêteté
intellectuelle un chemin ce chemin est
exigeant il implique que l'on prenne le
temps du dialogue est que l'on soit
scrupuleusement honnête et que l'on
aille au goût du cheminement ensemble
c'est ce que je souhaite pour la corse
est ce que je veux essayer de faire
modestement dans la fonction de ministre
de l'intérieur qui m'a été confié
pour cela il faut prendre les problèmes
les uns derrière les autres
ce qui relève de l'urgence et les
analyser finement de manière à apporter
les réponses les plus pertinentes le
premier sujet qui nous a été posée et
celui du développement de l'économie et
du droit pour les corses de vivre en
corse sur une île prospère ayant une
chance de développer sa politique du
logement sa politique de développement
économique sa politique de croissance de
ses filiales d'excellents sa politique
de valorisation de ses atouts agricoles
d'abord je veux rappeler que la
politique de la république n'a jamais
consisté à laisser la corse deux côtés
mais au contraire a tenté de
l'accompagner toujours je le veux pas
rappeler tout ce qu'ont fait les
gouvernements successifs par delà les
sensibilités politiques mais il y a de
cela dix ans tout juste le gouvernement
de lionel jospin promettait de mettre
sur le métier un programme
d'investissements pour la corse qui
s'est déployée au cours des 6 10
dernières années qui a conduit madame la
sénatrice à mettre près de 2 milliards
d'euros sur le métier dont 1,7 milliard
émaner de l'état pour faire des
investissements structurants qui ont
permis à la corse de connaître un taux
de croissance bien supérieur à celui
d'autres régions du continent
ces taux de croissance au cours des dix
dernières années supérieure à 2 %
auraient pu donner envie à bien des
régions qui n'ont pas bénéficié de
soutiens aussi significatif de la part
de l'état pour accompagner le
développement de leur territoire mais il
était normal que l'état décida de le
faire parce qu'il ya des obstacles et
des handicaps consubstantielle à
l'insularité que la corse n'avait pas
vocation à surmonter seuls et qui
conduisait l'équipe l'état à mettre en
place ce programme exceptionnel
d'investissement qui a contribué parmi
d'autres actions à faire la croissance
de la corse au cours des dix dernières
années mais aujourd'hui autour de ces
enjeux du développement il y à deux
questions essentielles qui se posent
et qui font l'objet des réflexions de
l'assemblée territoriale de corse et des
propositions qu'elle nous adresse
il y a deux propositions qui concernent
le développement économique la
possibilité pour les corses de vivre en
corse un meilleur accès à la propriété
au logement ce qui est bien légitime et
puis la question
plus spécifique mais ô combien important
aux yeux de la corse et de ce qu'y
habitent de la possibilité de participer
de parler encore la langue corse je veux
traiter de ces trois sujets et puis je
conclure en en évoquant un ou deux
autres en essayant de faire en sorte que
sur ces trois sujets
l'ensemble des questions de droits
de politique de relations avec la
république soit abordé sans rien
occulter première question la question
de la propriété
et de la possibilité d'avoir accès au
logement elle revêt deux sujets recouvre
deux sujets différents
connexes et complexe le premier sujet
est celui de fameux arrêtés miot
qui ont doté la corse d'un dispositif
particulier jusqu'à présent en matière
de droits de succession
rendu nécessaire par la difficulté pour
la corde reconstituer ces titres de
propriété
pour des raisons très ancienne qu'on
c'était au début du 19e siècle en 1800 à
très exactement et qui depuis minus 1801
n'ont pas réussi être surmontée à la
fois par des solutions de droit et par
la reconstitution des titres de
propriété
eux-mêmes
sur ce sujet là on ne peut pas dire de
ce gouvernement qu'il est était inerte
qu'il est était sourd qu'il est était
autiste est indifférent aux expressions
et aux interrogations formulées par les
élus de corse j'ai passé suffisamment de
temps dans cette assemblée au moment de
l'adoption de la loi de finances
rectificative et de la loi de finances
initiale avec beaucoup d'entre vous
comme à l'assemblée nationale pour que
vous ne vous souveniez pas du nombre
d'amendements que nous avons discuté
parfois d'ailleurs dans la réticence des
membres de cette assemblée qui
considérait que les dispositifs que nous
préconisions pour la corse et sur
lesquels le gouvernement avait donné un
avis de sagesse n'est pas tes pas
conforme au droit constitutionnel
malgré tout le gouvernement a souhaité
appuyer ces amendements en contribuant à
leur rédaction en écoutant les acteurs
corse en donnant un avis de sagesse
parce que nous avions parfaitement
conscience que des moyens
supplémentaires donnés aux girtec ne
suffiraient pas et qu'il fallait donner
le temps à la corse de reconstituer ces
titres de propriété de telle sorte à ce
qu'une fiscalité de droit commun à terme
relatives aux droits de succession
puisse s'appliquer
à l'époque
beaucoup de juristes appelé notre
attention mon attention j'ai été
ministre du budget sur les problèmes
constitutionnels que tout cela risquait
de poser à terme
d'autres juristes prétextant que le
droit n'était pas une science exacte
m'interpeller en disant que la vie
généralement exprimées par des
constitutionnalistes chevronnés et
reconnue
n'était pas nécessairement le droit et
qu'il fallait tenter un autre chemin en
écoutant à la fois les juristes de l'île
et d'autres qui avait pour elle de la
sympathie et le conseil constitutionnel
a tranché en indiquant qu'elle était le
droit
moi je ne commande pas l'autorité la
chose jugée parce que l'autorité de la
chose jugée existe je l'a constaté
lorsque le droit a été dit par le juge
constitutionnel
il ne nous reste plus qu'une solution
c'est de tenir compte de ce considérant
pour essayer d'élaborer d'autres normes
qui cette fois ci passe je veux redire
ici aux élus de corse qui sont présents
comme à ceux qui nous écoutent la
détermination du gouvernement à trouver
en très étroite liaison avec la
représentation nationale un chemin
qui ne remettent pas en cause le
principe d'égalité et qui permettrait
à la représentation nationale d'adopter
des dispositions relatives à la
reconstitution des titres propriété qui
vaudrait pour la totalité du territoire
national équivalent pour la totalité du
territoire national pourrait aussi
valoir pour la corse
voilà pour le premier sujet
je n'ai pas le sentiment madame la
sénatrice en vous disant cela de faire
montre d'une quelconque fermeture
d'esprit
j'ai bien le sentiment inverse d'être à
la fois ouvert souple est déterminé à
trouver une solution c'est d'ailleurs
assez cohérent avec ce que nous avons
fait jusqu'à présent car je le vois pas
pourquoi j'aurais passé autant de temps
dans le cadre de l'élaboration des lois
de finances précédent pour trouver un
chemin que subitement je fermerai après
avoir lu les considérants du conseil
constitutionnel qui disent qu'elle est
la voie de droit emprunter pour aboutir
parce que ce qui compte lorsqu'il s'agit
de politique et de droit ce n'est pas le
prendre des postures ce n'est pas de se
faire plaisir c'est de trouver un schéma
qui permette d'aboutir à une solution et
si la solution endroit n'est pas
opportune
le chemin abouti à quoi à une impasse et
une impasse
c'est le contraire d'une solution en
politique
donc fermer une porte sur une impasse ce
n'est pas fermé une porte sur toutes les
autres solutions qui se présentent
c'est fermer une porte sur une impasse
pour ouvrir des portes opportune sur des
solutions qu'ils en soient vraiment
voilà pour ce qui concerne les arrêtés
miot deuxième sujet sur lequel j'ai été
interpellé c'est le sujet du statut de
résident
la ctc a ouvert un débat
en proposant pour régler le problème de
la pression qui s'exerce sur le foncier
de la spéculation qui l'accompagnent et
qui peut se trouver à l'origine d'un
coût de sortie des logements qu'ils
soient prohibitif pour des corses qui
n'ont pas les moyens d'accéder à la
propriété de se loger la collectivité
territoriale de corse propose un statut
de résident qui ouvrira la possibilité
d'accéder à la propriété à ceux qui
depuis longtemps cinq ans résident ray
en corse il se trouverait ainsi dans la
possibilité d'accéder au dispositif
est ce que la proposition de la
collectivité territoriale de corse
mérite le mépris
du gouvernement et de la collectivité et
de l'assemblée nationale et du sénat en
aucun cas je n'ai jamais considéré que
le problème posé était un problème qui
ne se posait pas je n'ai jamais
considéré que la question de la
spéculation foncière était un mauvais
problème
c'est simplement émis puisqu'il s'agit
de dialogue
dans le dialogue il faut être deux et
simplement considéré qu'il était
important dès lors qu'une proposition
nous étaient faites par l'assemblée de
corse d'exprimer une réponse étayé
expertise et qui permettent dans le
cadre de ce dialogue respectueux de dire
aux élus de corse
ce que nous pensions après expertise de
la voix qui avait été emprunté
cette proposition de la collectivité
territoriale de corse pose deux
problèmes
le premier problème
c'est celui du principe d'égalité
face
la propriété
qui est un principe éminemment
républicain qui renvoie à la déclaration
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen de
1789 et qui comme l'a souvent dit le
sénateur alfonsi avec justesse fait
partie du bloc de constitutionnalité
on dit donc
il faudrait changer la constitution
si changer la constitution était une
manière de régler le problème pourquoi
pas mais il s'avère que le droit
européen après que la constitution
aurait été changé
nous empêcherait de continuer à faire
bénéficier la corse dès du bénéfice du
droit européen et des subventions qui
l'accompagnent puisque la corse se
retrouvera en contravention avec les
principes du droit européen puisque ce
dispositif a été adopté dans des pays de
l'union de façon transitoire pour des
pays entrants dans l'union européenne or
nous nous sommes dans l'union européenne
depuis longtemps et le dispositif
n'aurait pas vocation à être appliquée
de façon transitoire et de façon pérenne
donc nous avons un problème de droit
constitutionnel et nous avons un
problème de droit européen est ce que
dira dans un débat lorsqu'on est chargé
c'est le rôle de l'état
constitutionnellement du contrôle de
légalité qu'une des la bia délibération
pourrait ne pas être légale en raison du
divorce qu'elle instaure avec des
principes constitutionnels et de droit
européen est une manière de fermer des
portes et de refuser dialogue non c'est
une manière simplement de dire le droit
quand on est en charge du contrôle de
légalité ça s'appelle aussi la
république
est ce que c'est une manière de dire
qu'aucun chemin ne peut être empruntée
pour régler ce problème non la réflexion
juridique peut se poursuivre le propre
d'un débat et d'un dialogue c'est
d'accepter l'argumentation de l'autre y
compris lorsque n'est pas conforme à ce
que l'on pense
c'est l'idée que je me fais du dialogue
dans la république la richesse des
débats est d'autant plus grande que les
points de vue sont différents et que
l'on accepte d'accéder au point de vue
de l'autre c'est aussi ça la république
et par conséquent je propose simplement
que l'état ayant fait connaître sa
position en droit sur ce sujet nous
puissions continuer de façon
républicaine à dialoguer pour trouver
les solutions en existe-t-il oui je le
pense
la mise en place d'un établissement
public foncier en corse permettant à la
puissance publique d'acquérir les
emprises foncières sur lesquels la
spéculation à la plus grande pour éviter
que le coût du foncier ne continue à
augmenter que la corse continue à se
trouver confrontées à la possibilité
de réaliser des logements dans des
conditions qui soient compatibles avec
le revenu des corses me paraît être une
solution possible je le dis pour madame
la sénatrice qui m'invite à ouvrir des
portes
après m'avoir presque reprocher d'en
avoir fermé brutalement je les ai fermé
avec douceur esprit de vérité et j'en
ouvre toute grande vers des solutions
qui me paraissent possible et
immédiatement susceptibles d'être mises
en oeuvre s'appellera bien entendu de la
part du gouvernement la manifestation
d'une volonté d'entrer dans cette virée
de l'année dans cette direction ça ne
justifiera pas d'ailleurs une fin de
discussion sur tous les autres sujets y
compris celui ci dans sa dimension
juridique mais si l'on veut agir vite
pour trouver des solutions rapidement il
vaut mieux emprunter les chemins les
plus courts surtout si l'on est soucieux
des solutions efficaces le troisième
sujet celui de la langue
j'entends beaucoup d'élus de corse mais
pas simplement des élus des citoyens me
dire leur tristesse de voir leur langue
s'étioler
et d'avoir le sentiment que cette langue
qu'ils aiment qu'ils ont raison d'aimer
parce qu'elle est belle
leur crainte de voir cette langue qui ne
seraient plus parler justifient de leur
part expression d'une préoccupation
eh bien je trouve cette préoccupation
légitime
ce que je trouve moins légitime ou en
tous les cas ce que je trouve
intéressant qu'il est ce que je trouve
qu'il est intéressant de débattre c'est
le chemin que l'on nous propose
d'emprunter pour atteindre le but du
développement de la langue corse en
corse
la solution proposée est celle de la co
officialité de la langue corse
que signifie la co officialité de la
langue corse
la co officialité de la langue corse
signifie je le dis à notre ami le
sénateur dantec qui m'invitait à
apporter une réponse précise sur ce
sujet que nous n'arrêtons pas au
bilinguisme
mais que nous pesons le principe que
pour accéder à l'emploi public en corse
il faudrait être en situation de
répondre en corse à ceux qui parmi des
corses déciderait de s'adresser à
l'administration en corse
moi je ne suis pas du tout choquée que
l'on puisse dans l'administration en
corse répondant en corse et des corses
qui s'adresse pas l'administration en
corse ce qui me gêne c'est que l'on
fasse de la maîtrise de la langue corse
même dans ses premiers prolégomènes une
obligation pour accéder à la fonction
publique en corse parce que si nous
décidions de faire cela ça signifierait
tout simplement que le principe
d'égalité des citoyens français face à
l'exercice des charges publiques qui est
un principe fondamental conclut contenu
aussi dans la déclaration des droits de
l'homme de 1789 et qui est un principe
auquel la fonction publique dans notre
pays qui a beaucoup s'en trouvera est
remise en cause et je ne suis même pas
sûr que si nous accédons à cette demande
nous serions garantie pour autant que le
corps serait davantage parler parce que
la co officialité de la langue corse
avec les conséquences que je viens
d'indiquer ne donne aucune garantie sur
le fait que l'éducation nationale de
l'école primaire jusqu'à l'université
dotera les universités les écoles
d'enseignants permettant de développer
l'apprentissage de la langue corse
encore pour que la langue soit davantage
parler
je considère donc que cette suggestion
telle qu'elle est proposée pose un
problème de droit que je vient
d'exprimer mais ne remplit pas
nécessairement l'office qu'elle prétend
remplie parce que vous pouvez
qu'officialiser
toutes les langues si vous n'apprenez
pas à ceux qui sont sur le territoire de
l'est par les fautes d'enseignants et de
moyens dans le système éducatif vous
raté la cible
alors moi je ne suis pas désireux qu'on
rate les cibles je suis désireux compare
le corps son corps
je suis désireux qu'on développe la
pratique du corps sont corse et je crois
que les langues sont une richesse et que
le français comme le disait le sénateur
dantec n'a pas de raison d'avoir peur du
fait qu'on parle de corse en corse à
condition que cela se fasse dans un
cadre qui soit conforme mme aux
principes de la république et qui
garantissent que la cible sera atteint
par la mobilisation des moyens de l'état
dans le système éducatif qui permette 2
donc je le redis ici au sénat avec la
même sincérité et la même exigence de
rigueur que celle que j'ai voulu mettre
dans mon propos en corse la volonté du
gouvernement n'est pas de fermer des
portes elle est d'ouvrir les bonnes
les bonnes qui permettent d'atteindre
les bonnes solutions pour régler les
problèmes auxquels la corse est
confronté aujourd'hui
et qui sont des problèmes auxquels nous
faut faire face maintenant
parce que je voudrais conclure sur deux
points
préconisé une réforme constitutionnelle
qui impliquerait qu'on inscrive les
dispositions concernant la corse dans la
constitution dont il faudrait définir le
contenu
supposerait que l'on soit en situation
de réunir une majorité qualifiée au
parlement pour les faire voter
et réunir une majorité de trois
cinquièmes au parlement pour faire voter
une réforme constitutionnelle
ne dépend pas de la seule volonté de la
collectivité territoriale de corse
et on pourra tordre le problème dans
tous les sens c'est pas simplement un
problème de droit même si c'est aussi un
problème de droit parce que la majorité
qualifiée elle est inscrite dans la
constitution c'est un problème politique
pour faire votre disposition
constitutionnelle il faut une majorité
qualifiée au parlement je ne suis pas
sûr que cette majorité existe et comme
je ne suis pas sûr que cette majorité
existe conditionné à la réunion de cette
majorité la résolution des problèmes de
la corse serait hautement aléatoire là
on nous explique que ces problèmes sont
urgents donc si les problèmes sont
urgents traitons les tout de suite dans
le cadre juridique existant pour faire
en sorte que les problèmes soient réglés
sans tarder puisqu'il sont urgents et le
prenons pas le risque d'engager des
discussions aléatoire
visant à la mobilisation de majorité
tente on ne sait pas si elles existent
pour régler à long terme des problèmes
dont on me dit qu'ils relèvent de
l'urgence est à dire du court terme
et comme il n'ya pas de long terme nous
il n'y a pas de terre
régler les problèmes à court terme de la
corse n'obère en rien la possibilité de
les régler de façon plus ambitieux
encore en long terme dès lors qu'il y
aurait
une possibilité d'aller plus loin dans
la réflexion juridique et de faire en
sorte que les conditions politiques
soient réunies pour les régler alors
vrai conclure sur un point
quand tes bras même sont compliquées
endroit
techniquement politiquement
plus sonné pour tenter de les régler
dans la bonne foi et la sincérité des
les chutes d'un échange plus on a de
chance de les régler ensemble
pour les régler ensemble dans la bonne
foi il faut éviter de se faire des
procès reposant non pas sur ce que l'on
a dit
on pas sur les propos que l'on a tenu
mais sur les intentions que l'on vous
prêterait dans l'oubli des propos tenus
par tous ceux qui se sont exprimés avant
vous
parce que des gens se sont exprimés en
corse avant moi et des gens sont
exprimés avant moi à paris sur la corse
ils ont tous dit qu'elle était le cadre
juridique dans lequel les choses
pouvaient s'engager
generali de plus il de moi encore ce que
ce qu'avait dit ce qui s'était exprimé
avant moi je les ferme et emporte
occupant encore aucune porte j'ai voulu
en corse dire quelles étaient les aléas
d'un chemin complexe et incertain
non pas pour altérer une volonté non pas
pour décevoir
non pas pour
désespérer non pas pour casser des
enthousiasmes mais pour mobiliser les
enthousiastes dans une direction au
terme de laquelle il est un chemin une
lumière une issue une solution
est par ailleurs je n'ai pas non plus
fermer le débat sur la question
institutionnelle
y compris dans sa dimension
constitutionnel parce que la dimension
constitutionnel c'est plus que la
dimension institutionnelle
on peut régler débat institutionnel dans
le cas de la constitution actuelle où
aller plus loin
c'est simplement dit
que sur ces sujets là ce qui importe
c'est le résultat ce n'est pas la
posture c'est le but ce n'est pas le
fétichisme du droit ou de telle ou telle
inscription normatives dans tel ou tel
texte c'est de faire en sorte que
l'accord se trouvent des solutions à ces
problèmes et je veux ici au sénat à la
faveur de ce débat organisé à
l'initiative de nicolas alfonsi redire à
travers cette assemblée aux corses par
delà leur sensibilité
par delà leurs options par delà leur
volonté qui sont diverses et multiples
sur tous les sujets que nous venons
d'évoquer qu'ils trouveront toujours
dans ce gouvernement un gouvernement
ouvert à l' écoute attentif désireux de
trouver des solutions
désireux d'éviter des impasses rigoureux
dans la proche qu'il fera des textes et
du droit parce que les textes et le
droit ont parfois quelque chose à voir
avec la politique quand on convoque la
rigueur et de le faire dans le respect
de ce qu'ils délibèrent en nous posant
des questions que j'estime juste même si
les questions les réponses apportées ne
le sont pas toujours autant que nous
pourrions le souhaitez
j'espère que ce débat aura contribué à
préciser les choses et j'espère que nous
aurons d'autres occasions de nous revoir
pour aller plus au fond des sujets
car la question de la corse est une
question qui mobilise nos assemblées
depuis longtemps c'est une question trop
passionnante pour qu'elle cesse de les
mobiliser demain et c'est une question
trop exigeante pour qu'elle ne soit pas
abordée avec toutes les exigences de la
rigueur intellectuelle
voilà le ministre de l'intérieur bernard
cazeneuve a donc finalement conclu ce
débat vous l'avez vu il a été applaudi
par l'ensemble des groupes du sénat le
ministre de l'intérieur qui est
intervenu pour tenir un discours
pragmatique il faut tenir en compte des
spécificités corse sans pour autant se
faire retoquer par le conseil
constitutionnel et faire très attention
donc au cadre juridique
le ministre de l'intérieur qui est
intervenu aussi bien sur le
développement économique de l'île de
beauté que sur la question du foncier
corps soit encore sur la question de la
préservation de la langue vous pouvez
toujours voir et revoir toutes les
séances sur notre site sur
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez vous de
l'actualité parlementaire cet après midi
à 16h30 pour l'audition d'henri proglio
sur la transition énergétique très bonne
journée sur les chaînes parlementaires